So, so far, where have
we gotten to? We, uh,
we started summarizing what
general equilibrium was.
We saw that Irving Fischer of Yale
reinvented general equilibrium in order to
study finance.
And we saw that just by reinterpreting
the variables of general equilibrium,
we could start to say a lot
of things about finance.
And in particular we had the idea of free
markets and argument in favor of free
markets. We had the idea of
arbitrage and no arbitrage.
So you could deduce a lot of prices
without solving for the whole like Librium
just by knowing what other
prices are and we deduce,
and we also learned that the price of
many things is going to have to do with
the utility and margin
utilities of people.
And that's going to have a lot to do
with what their impatience is and whether
they're rich people or poor people who,
you know,
redistributes redistribution of wealth,
who's got the money and how impatient
the people who have the money are.
So those are the basic lessons that
we're going to now carry into the course.
And so for several lectures now I'm
going to leave the abstract theory of
general equilibrium and start
teaching you some of the basic
vocabulary of finance
that you have to know.
And that everybody in finance
knows like what is a mortgage,
what's an annuity and stuff like that.
So before I go there though,
I want to remind you of
what Irving Fisher done. So,
uh, of what Shakespeare had done 300 years
before Irving Fisher. So Irving Fisher,
a member, he, he cleared up the
confusion of what interest was. He said,
interest is crystallized impatience.
It's not some horribly unjust thing.
It's not as Marx thought exploitation,
but, but a Shakespeare had
discovered all this 300 years before.
Now when I was your age and are a little
bit younger than you in high school,
we all had to read the merchant of Venice.
I have a two Indian coauthors
and who are vaguely my age,
maybe a little bit older,
but anyway, they, um,
so grew up in India and they had
to learn the merchant of Venice.
And actually they learned
it a lot better than I did.
They both have memorize
the merchant of Venice,
they can recite almost the entire
thing by heart. And uh, but anyway,
when I was in high school is completely
typical to study the merchant of Venice.
I wonder how many of you
have actually read it?
Who's read the merchant of Venice?
Okay, well, I mean, well this is Yale.
I'm shocked. Okay, so a quarter
of you have read it. Well,
I recommended the other three
quarters that you do read it.
Now when it's taught nowadays,
especially at Yale,
it's taught as a love story and
a commentary on antisemitism.
Now of course, uh, it's both.
It is a love story in a commentary and
antisemitism Shylock the lender is Jewish.
And remember what we heard about
the great religions, you know,
they're all forbidding lending it
interest except for Judaism would let,
let you Lynne,
low loan money at interest to non Jews.
So Shakespeare whose the money lender
is Jewish and lending it to Christians.
And that plays a big role in
the play. Um, and you know,
what happens to them and you know,
what people say about Judaism
is a big element of the story,
but the way the play is red now,
that's the whole story.
And I don't think it's the whole story.
In fact,
I think it's quite an
unimportant part of the story.
I think the heart of the story is
Shakespeare's commentary on economics.
And so I'm going to try and argue in
the next 10 minutes that Shakespeare was
not only a great writer, a great
psychologist, but a great economist,
and you're going to see that almost all
the elements of the course are in this
play. And that if you read it the
way I think you should read it,
it should be obvious that it's really
about economics and not about love.
So how do you know that? Well,
the very first line of the play,
Antonio walks in and he says, and
sooth, I know not why I'm so sad.
And there's an interlocutor,
a minor character whose name I've
forgotten sylaria or something says, well,
it must be that you're so nervous.
You know, you've got all your,
all your riches are on, on, you know,
on these boats and they're there,
they're at risk.
And so anyone who had so much money at
risk on boats would naturally be nervous
and therefore maybe depressed.
And Antonio says, no, no, no, no.
I'm not worried about the boats because
every boat is on a different ocean.
And so I'm not worried. You know,
they're at a different ocean and they're,
they're sailing at different times.
I'm not worried about my boats.
And so then the interlocutor says,
well, venue must be worried about love.
And he says, no, no, that's not it at all.
So what do we see at the very beginning
of the play? It's business first,
love second,
and secondly,
he understands diversification. Okay, so
now what is the plot of the play?
But Sanyo who?
Harold Bloom. So it happens that
I went to talk to Harold bloom.
I saw him and the Whitney humanity center.
Yale's one of the greatest scholars.
And among, you know, he's a, he's a
polymath. He knows about everything,
but including about Shakespeare.
And he is a much advertised
a photographic memory.
So I happened to run into them at
the Whitney Humanity Center, uh,
actually in the men's room of
the Whitney humanity center. And,
uh, I asked while we were there,
I asked him about,
uh,
the merchant of Venice and whether he
happened to remember the rate of interest
that a Shylock ends up charging Antonio.
And he said,
um, he said, dear boy, I
remember almost everything,
but that I forgotten.
It was so unimportant to him that he
didn't even remember the rate of interest.
So,
but he said,
I happen to be lecturing
about the merchant of Venice
in my class this afternoon.
So I went and heard his lecture and
the merchant of Venice. So Bizani Oh,
who's one of the heroes of the play?
Uh,
according to Harold Bloom
is a complete loser.
He's the one who needs
the money to wool Portia,
who is this beautiful,
a woman living outside of Venice.
And so he's got a borrow, a huge
amount of money. So he, when he enters,
he's described as a Venetian,
a scholar, and a soldier. Now,
whatever Shakespeare says, uh, this,
you know, a scholar and a soldier,
sometimes it's not a venetian. When he
says that the guy, always a great guy.
So this occurs repeatedly in Estonia.
Obasanjo comes in as a star,
he's a Venetian, a scholar, a
soldier, what more can you want to be?
And so he needs the money to war to whoop
Porsche and he's got a business plan
to do it. He's tried wooing
her before, you know,
and it's got its come to nothing and he's
lost his money. But he says, you know,
if you shoot an Arrow and you lose it,
shoot an Arrow again the same way and
then follow the second era more closely
and you'll figure out
where the first Arrow goes.
So he's a man on a business
venture with a business plan.
So here's [inaudible] and
here's a Shylock and Antonio.
Now he needs 3000 duckets and he,
you know,
he doesn't have any
collateral or anything.
And so he goes to Antonio,
who's an older man and,
uh, you know, according to Harold Bloom,
there's some potential gay
relationship and you know,
maybe their lovers and maybe they're not
lovers and you know, there, that's path,
the lecture anyway,
so
Shylock Lens, the money, 3000
dockets, and it's so much money,
he has to borrow it from another,
uh,
money lender's going to ball who's
even richer than he is. Okay.
So they argue over what the
interest rate's got to be.
And so Antonio says, uh, oh dear,
I forgotten to change the, the,
so this is out of order. So they argue
over what the interest rate should be.
And Antonio and Shylock,
um, make this argument,
Antonio says, you know, it's a disgusting
that you want to charge me interest.
I mean, good Christians never charged
interest. I'm appalled that you, you know,
it's because you're Jewish, you're
charging me interest. So he's,
he's throwing epithets and insults at shy,
like,
but really he just wants a low
interest rate. And so, um, he says,
Antonio says,
Shylock,
I would neither neither borrow
Norland by taking or giving interest,
but to supply the ripe ones of my friend,
I'll break a custom.
So ripe wants of my friend that's saying
because best Sanyo is so impatient to
get his hands on the money
to find, you know, a Porsche,
she's going to get married
if he doesn't hurry up.
And Mary are himself
because of his impatience.
He's willing to pay a high rate of
interest. And Shylock says, you know,
you're always complaining about
me that I, that I, uh, you know,
charge interest in your, you know,
I've left out a whole bunch of stuff,
but you know, I'm patient, you
know, all of us, our patient,
that's the badge of our tribe.
We're patient.
And so that's why I'm willing
to lend you the money.
So he or Shakespeare has laid out
and it goes over five patients pages,
patience and impatience.
Okay. So the, in the, uh,
so then they get in an argument
again about interests and, and, um,
uh, uh, okay, so I forgot to slide.
So the argument is Antonio tells a
Shylock tells a story. He says, you know,
even in the Bible you say that it's
Unchristian, uh, to lend it interest.
But don't you know the story in the
Bible where, where Jacob was asked to do,
perform a service in the
field using his fields. Uh,
somebody wanted to use this
field for awhile. And so Jacob,
okay can use my fields,
but I have to charge you a fee.
And the fee's going to be that.
However it spotted lamb,
many spotted lambs are born.
Those are the ones that I get.
And so it turned out that there was a
huge number of spotted lambs. And so,
um, although Jacob had lent some
of his sheep and his fields to,
to the person who wanted them,
he got back vastly more than he lent
the beginning. And so Antonio Answers,
well, this is an interest. This
is a, you know, this is a risk.
Jacob got so much more because he took
a risk who would have known how many
lambs were going to be born. And so it's
really, you don't really charge interest.
You're just a,
you're an investor.
So they haggle over this for awhile
and they come to the conclusion that,
uh,
he's going to lend the money.
And so what is the interest that
they actually end up charging?
The thing that a Harold bloom
couldn't remember? Well, zero, okay,
I'll lend you the money and take no
Dwan of uses for my money's not a single
interest for my money, but they have
to negotiate something else. Something,
uh, besides the rate of interest,
they have to negotiate the collateral.
And so they said, so they say, you know,
go with me, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then, uh, let the forfeit
be nominated if you don't pay,
but the forfeit be an equal pound of
your fare. Flash to be cut off and taken.
And what part of your body pleased
with me. Now the other half of the,
there were two lectures by Harold bloom.
Half the second half of the first lecture
was what part of the body is he really
talking about? And there seemed to
be only two possibilities, but uh,
so the heart and another possibility
and Harold bloom favored.
The second possibility.
But anyway,
it's collateral that they're
putting up for the loan. So, um,
okay, so there's collateral.
So now what happens?
So what we found is that Shakespeare
has understood the impatience,
theory of interest. You've got an
impatient bar and a patient lender,
and it's the trade off between
patients and impatience,
which is going to decide
what the rate of interest is.
So that's already Irvin
Fischer's biggest message.
And then the second thing he's noticed,
which Irving Fisher didn't notice at all,
is that w, and this is going to be a
large part of the rest of the course.
How do we know these people are
going to keep their promises?
Why is Antonio going to keep his promises?
Well,
it's because he's putting up collateral
and Antonio is stepping in for Bizani.
Oh. Uh, because, uh, his collateral is
worth more than Bizani owes, you know,
shy like once his pound of flesh, not
Bizani. I was pound of flesh. So, uh,
all right. So that's the, that's
the beginning, by the way,
just how does the play unfold
against more interesting.
So what happens is after getting his
money, uh, Bassania then goes to woo woo,
fair Porsche. And how does he wore? Well,
it turns out the way that her fabulously
wealthy father has set up the marriage
is there three caskets, a gold
one, silver one and a lead one.
And he has to pick one.
And one of them contains her picture.
And if you get the one with her picture,
you get to Merrier if you pick the wrong
one. And here's the shocking thing.
If you get the wrong one, you swear
before you choose. If you choose wrong,
never to speak to lady
afterward and way of marriage.
So not only don't you get Porsche,
you don't get anybody.
So what is the purpose of this absurd?
A contract?
Well, the purpose is maybe to make sure
that people really want to marry her.
Maybe the father set it up so that only
one who really wanted to marry her would
bother to enter this competition
because the risk is so high.
But another way of saying it is it gives
an excuse to Shakespeare to talk about
risk and return. And how, you know,
people who have a higher risk or an
expect a higher return and Morocco's you
know,
so that's,
so they talk about risk and return and
Aragon basically says she's really not,
you know, she's not that good looking
to justify such a high risk. But anyway,
but all those other guys pick the wrong
casket and bizono picks the lead one and
uh, gets her. And so, uh,
so she becomes the wife.
And of course she's delighted
by this. He's, she's the one,
he's the one she wanted all
along. And so she says, uh,
let me give you this ring. And, uh,
you know, this is yet a third contract.
The first contract is the loan of Shylock.
The second contract is the, is the,
the choosing the caskets and the,
you know,
a contract that you won't marry
again if you choose wrong.
And now we have a third contract,
which is Porsche deciding that, um,
she gives a ring to besides neo and CFO.
And she says,
let this ring represent your love.
And he says,
when this bring parts from this finger,
then parts of life from hands,
I'll never lose this ring. I'll
never give it up. I love you so much.
So of course the boat's appear to
sink, you know, calamity appears.
My ships of all ms credited, you know, um,
Shylock wants is
collateral. So Portia, uh,
now who turns out to be incredibly
wealthy. So we realized, again,
the play is not about love. She's
beautiful, but she's fabulously rich.
Much richer than Shylock is much
less richer than two ball was.
They had to scrounge around
to get the 300 dockets.
She hands 6,000 duckets
and then 12,000 dockets.
Then 36,000 Duckett says, look, you know,
offer Shylock all this money. You know,
tell him here I've got the money. Tell him
not to take his pound of flesh. So, uh,
they hold a trial to decide
whether Shylock should get
his pound of flesh or not.
And so shy by this time is
incredibly pissed off at, uh,
to say the least at Antonio and
beside you. And why is he so angry?
Because among other things,
his daughter,
Jessica has run off with a Christian
named Lorenzo and stolen his money.
And so he tells my daughter might
dockets. And so she sells his, uh,
she sold his, his wife's
ring who, um, for,
for a monkey. And he said, or his ring
that was given to him by his wife, Leah.
And he says,
I had it of Leah when I was a bachelor.
I would not have given it
for a wilderness of monkeys.
So Shylock believes in
keeping his promise.
He would never have broken a promise.
He never would have given away the
ring that was given to him by his wife.
He absolutely wouldn't do it.
He believes in keeping promises,
unlike everybody else in the
play, his daughter, you know,
everybody as we'll see. So, um,
so s another Lancelot says this,
making of Christians will raise the
price of hogs. This, this Jewish girl,
Jessica,
has it become a Christian.
So now she's going to be able to eat
pork if it's going to increase the demand
for pork and therefore raise the
price of hogs. So Shakespeare,
the play is full of economics. It's
all about teaching economics. Okay.
So and so anyway,
they,
they go to the trial and a Shylock
thinks the guy's a complete fool.
He doesn't understand interest.
You don't understand the whole point
of a marriage contract. I mean,
not have a marriage contract of a
lending contract and getting interest.
And basically he says, I got to skip over
this little quickly. He says, you know,
I've, we've got a contract.
Your city, the greatest, uh,
commercial city in the world at that
time can't possibly survive if you don't
uphold contracts.
So if you deny me fine upon your law,
there is no force in the decrees
of Venice. I stand for judgment,
I stand for keeping promises. And the
law is supposed to enforce promises.
I stand for laws, which I liked,
says now that at the trial,
who turns out to be the judge,
will Porsche has disguised herself as
the judge and she's actually the judge.
And so she comes in and she has this
famous line who is the merchant here in
which is the Jew. So again, this
confirms to me it's about economics.
If she was about Judaism, it would be
who's the Christian and who's the Jewish.
She saying, who's the borrower and who's
the lender? That's how she comes in.
And so then she says,
you've got to show mercy and this
is the most famous line in the play,
the quality of mercy, blah, blah. You all
remembered who seen it. And uh, he says,
um, and then, and then beside Neil
says, look, I've got 6,000 dockets.
I've got more than that. Take that. And he
says, you know, a contract is a contract.
You humiliated me. All kinds of
humiliations of happened to me.
I've got feelings too. I've been
humiliated. I want the contract.
And the contract says that I
should get the pound of flesh.
And so besides Leo says, you know, to
do a great right, do a little wrong.
Okay. So, you know, deaf, you
know, let him default. And so, uh,
so what does Porsche say? What
is the judgment? It sounds she,
she has to play the judge.
It seems like the whole city
depends on enforcing contracts.
And here it seems like
a horrible thing to do.
You're going to have to kill somebody.
So what judgment can she possibly,
possibly mate? She says, well, the
state has to enforce contracts.
Of course contracts have to be enforced,
but only good contracts
should be enforced.
And so what's wrong with the contract?
Does she say we're going to reduce
what you owe from 3000 to, you know,
1500? Does she, you know, that's
principal forgiveness. Does she say,
uh, just say you don't have to,
you know, what does she say?
What she says is that what was wrong
is the contract wasn't right. The Co,
it wasn't the interest
rate that was wrong.
It wasn't the amount
you owe that was wrong.
It was the collateral that was wrong.
So she says the right collateral was a
pound of flesh but not a drop of blood.
And so the state intervenes not
to change the interest rate,
not to change the principal, but to
change the collateral. Okay. So, um,
all right. So that, that's going
to turn out to be, you know,
the leverage was wrong.
And so the second, okay.
So then the play ends with
Bizono asking the judge,
he's so pleased that things have turned
out right. If he can reward the judge,
he doesn't know who the judge
is. And he says, you know,
I've got all these dockets that,
uh, I've just gotten, you know,
why don't I give you some of the dockets?
And the judge says, well, uh, no,
I don't want the dockets, but I notice
you've got this ring on your finger.
Why don't even give me that? And, uh,
you know, he says, well, I can't do that,
my Porsche's I've promised. And
the judge says, well, you know, um,
give it to me anyway. And he gives
her the ring. And so the play, uh,
finally ends with her revealing herself
and he's incredibly embarrassed that
he's given her the ring. So this is
another contract broken, another default,
and he, and then he says, but
I'm never going to default again.
And Antonio Steps in and says,
you know,
I'll guarantee again that
he'll never default again.
And of course we all know that
he's going to default. Okay.
So the whole play is just about contracts
and breaking contracts and figuring.
So at first it's about what
the rate of interest should be.
Then it switches to should contracts
always be enforced and yes,
they should be enforced,
but the enforcement should be the taking
of collateral and sometimes the amount
of collateral put up is Ron.
So that's going to be the conclusion of
this course that what went wrong in the
last two years or three years was a
horrible mistake about how much collateral
to be put up and the Fed instead of
just monitoring the interest rate,
which is what you're taught in
macroeconomics, is supposed to do,
should it be monitoring
a collateral as well?
And maybe even most
importantly. So I'm now, okay.
So with that introduction
to the rest of the course,
I don't know how convinced you are about
Shakespeare, the economist, but hey,
let's now switch to um,
learning some,
some of the basic words of finance.
So,
okay.
so I'm going to now follow pretty
closely what the notes are. Uh,
all right. So let's imagine a world
where we've solved for the equilibrium.
This could be the, you know, the
real world or in one of our models.
And there are many time periods,
not just two time periods.
So let's suppose that there as there are,
as we're going to see
in great detail later,
suppose it's possible to pay money today
in order to get a dollar next year or
pace in heart mountain of money today
in order to get a dollar in two years or
pay a different amount of money
today to get a dollar in three years.
So Pi Ti is the amount of money you
paid today to get a dollar at time.
T that's called a zero
because there's no coupon.
You just get something at the end. And so
though you'll, we'll see you next class.
You know,
we're going to start talking about real
real markets and what the prices of all
the Zeros are.
So anyway,
that Thai tea is something that is traded
in the market and everybody at every
hedge fund and every Wall Street Bank
knows what Pi t is at the beginning of
each day. Now Fisher said, well
don't get too lost thinking about Pi.
Ti think about PT, you
know, take out inflation.
You don't have to make an
expectation about what inflation is,
but assuming you're right,
you can figure out from these Pi teas
what PT is the present value price,
how much would you pay today and
goods to get an apple at time.
T not a dollar at time t
but an apple at time t.
So it involves knowing what inflation
is and what the price of apples is going
to be a tight time t. So Fisher said
there's a lot of stuff you can do,
but the Pi teas,
there's also more important stuff you
can do with the pts and you should always
keep those in mind. Okay. So, um,
let's take the simplest case where
piety is a constant interest rates.
There's a constant interest
rate. I, so if you ask, um,
what's a dollar worth today in terms of
how many dollars you can get next year?
It's one plus I, what's a dollar
worth today? In two years?
It's one plus ice squared. So putting
it backwards, a dollar in two years,
the price of it today,
it must be one over one plus I squared.
So a dollar in tears.
The value today is one plus I over t.
So this is just a simplification.
So,
so we'll see that lots of the jargon
of economics assumes that there's this
constant interest rate. Uh, that's,
that's determining all these prices.
Okay.
So
the first thing to realize is what
Fisher calls the present value price.
If there are some acid that paid off
money in the future and one through empty,
you don't have to solve the
whole equilibrium to figure
out what its price would
be if you knew the prices of these Zeros.
Pi one through Pi Ti because to get em
$2 a time to just costs you Pi $2 today.
So you add up the cost of buying
all the cashflows of the acid.
That has to be the price
of the asset today.
And if the prices of the Zeros are given
just by the interest rate discounting
it, then uh, then it's just,
and one of one plus I and to over one I
squared and empty over one plus r to the
T. I see there's a typo here. Oh No,
no, there's no type of,
it's one plus side of the t.
There are all these one
beside of the tea. Okay, so,
and now if the price weren't that,
if the price of this bond, we're,
we're bigger, we're let's say smaller
than this, uh, what would you do?
You would buy the bond and at the same
time you'd sell promises to deliver m one
m two and empty in the future.
If you sold those promises and nobody
doubted that you would keep your promise.
So this is something you know
Shakespeare wouldn't have,
would have been suspicious of. But if you
made those promises and no one doubted,
you'd keep them.
You could raise this much money by selling
all the promises so you get this much
money. If the bond costs less than
that, you could make all the promises,
get all the money, buy the
bond, have money leftover. Okay.
Then you'd have to keep all your promises.
But the bond itself would be paying you
money in the future that you could use
to keep all your promises.
So it has to be that this is the price
of the bond provided that everybody will
allow you to borrow and lend at those
rates of interest. Because if it weren't,
you would either buy the bond
and sell all the promises.
Or in the other case where the price
is higher, you'd sell the bond. Okay,
get all this money and
then, um, by all the,
use that money to buy all those promises.
Okay.
And then you could keep the promise,
then you could keep [inaudible].
You could make the payments of the bond
because the promises would come due to
you. So if you, in that case,
you'd have to believe people
who made promises to you.
So as long as nobody's doubting the
other people keeping their promises,
it has to be that by no arbitrage,
the price of a bond is just
the discounted cash flows.
That was Fisher's main principle.
Okay. So he saw that last time.
We're just going to do it. Uh, okay.
So we're now going to
introduce a few vocabulary.
So the first thing is the doubling rule.
So I think at least half
of you probably know this,
but you know it's a much better if you
can do things in your head than having to
calculate them all.
So the doubling rule says how many years
that I percent interest does it take to
double your money? So, um,
so you can just solve this.
Okay,
so one plus I to the end means that if
you take the logs of both sides and you
know that log of two is 0.69
then a 0.6 then then you know,
you take the log of both sides and
log one plus cy has to be log of two.
So anti equals 0.69 over
log of one plus Ai. Okay.
And so now log of one plus cy
you know is approximately I,
why is that?
So this is Taylor's really,
you don't actually have to know this if
you've never seen Taylor's rule before
but you know an approximation
of log of one plus Ai.
You know for any function f of x,
it's FFA plus f prime of a times x minus
eight plus one half f double prime of
eight times x minus h squared.
That's the standard Taylor's rule thing.
So therefore log of one plus I is log
of one and zero so it's going to be zero
plus I cause the derivative of the log
is one over x and that x equals one
that's one of her one.
So it's zero plus I and then the second
derivative is minus one over x squared
and x equals one that's minus one.
So with the half here,
the approximate log,
one plus size,
approximately zero plus PSI minus ice
squared over two so you can replace log of
one plus Psi with,
I mean 0.69 of her log of one plus the
eye with 0.69 over I'm minus I squared
over two so you know,
for very small interest rates I
squared is practically nothing.
So 0.69 over I,
you know,
if the interest rate is a is a 0.0 to
3% 0.0 to three that times and 0.69
divided by 0.023 is 30 so it
says that in at 2.3% interest,
you double your money in 30 years.
Well,
if I is 7% say the Nice Square to
starting to get a little bit bigger.
So I minus iceberg spirit over to his
0.07 I squared 0.049 over two that's
0.0675 so if I put in I ankles 0.07 it's
0.69 of her 0.0675 that's around right.
69 over 67 you know
there's a decimal things.
It's a little over 10 say 10.2 that's
like 0.7 to over 0.07 so that's 0.72 is
the doubling rule to get for interest
rates around 7% or 6% or 4% something like
that.
You know you're going to divide 90 to
69 but in [inaudible] 72 so 72 you know
the interest rate is 0.07 right?
Interest rate is a percent so it's,
it's a decimal thing.
So,
so 0.07 or 0.06 is like 72 over six so
at 6% it takes 12 years to double your
money.
So the rule,
the basic rule is he want to know how
long it takes at 6% interest to double
your money. You just take 72
divided by six and it's 12 years.
If it's 8% interest, 72 over eight is
about nine years. If it's a, you know,
10% interest, it's a little over seven
years to double your money. Okay?
And so that rule is incredibly useful
to keep in your head because you can do
all,
you can shock and amaze people by how
fast you can compute things that you know,
if you just remember that rule. So let's
just check the rule by the way. Um,
so suppose that you
have a $24 in the bank,
okay?
And you have 6% interest.
So here I took the $24
you look at the top,
you see that's the B one number,
and I've just multiplied it by
the interest rate 1.06 okay.
And so I keep doing that.
You know,
here I've multiplied the
thing above it by 1.06 again.
So I keep investing the money
at 6% interest over here,
I've invested the money at
7% interest. Okay? So anyway,
after 12 years you see the $24 you know,
this is year one.
So at year 1220 $4 has become 48
so it's a very good approximation.
And so 7% you know, it's supposed to
take a little over 10 years. So 10 years,
you're not quite there,
but 11 years you're past it.
You can see how we're starting with 24.
You can see how good the doubling rule is.
Okay? So that's just something to keep.
So we can now do in class lots of concrete
examples without having to take out
our calculators and stuff cause we can
do them in class in your head. All right,
so that's, so let's just do that now. Um,
okay.
Okay. So in fact, why
did I pick $24? Well,
this is a famous story you hear
in second grade, the Indians, uh,
sold Manhattan for $24 in 1646.
So how bad a deal was that for the
Indians? It looks incredibly stupid,
but actually, you know, interest
accumulates pretty fast.
So if you look at 6% interest,
okay,
so 360 years gets you to 2006.
That's a sort of round number at 6%.
So at 6% how long does it take to double?
It takes 12 years to double.
So that means at 6% interest,
you're doubling every 12 years.
So in 360 years,
you're going to double 30 times.
So in your head you can figure
out that doubling every 30 times,
you know,
doubling 30 times as two to the 30th and
of course two to the 10th is something
you should know.
It's 1024 you know,
so I'm sure you know that
number right to, to the, okay,
so it's one family that's
a good one to remember.
Two to the 10th is about a thousand so
a thousand cubed is about a billion.
So basically 24 becomes 24 billion.
So at 6% interest,
and they sold Manhattan for 24
billion in today's dollars. So that's,
that's pitifully low.
But if you look at 7% interest,
you can do the same calculation.
So it's 7% interest.
You should do this in your head now.
So it's going to double
every 72 over seven years.
So their 360 years,
about 360 is very round number.
So three 360 divided by 72 over
seven that's five times seven.
It's 35,
so two to the 35th while it's like
a billion times two to the fifth,
which is 32.
So it's a $1 becomes 32 billion,
but we started with $24.
So it's 768 billion.
So now you're starting to get a
little bit closer to what, um,
the value of Manhattan is.
I mean,
the value of all the real
estate in the country,
all the houses in the country used to
be 20 trillion and not sure how far
they've gone down. Now let's say
they're 15 trillion. Um, so 15 trillion.
You add commercial real estate,
you know,
maybe in the whole country
that's worth 25 trillion or 22.
But that went down too.
So let's say 20 trillion now,
how much of the 20 Chilean could
possibly be in New York City?
I've actually got no idea, but it
can't be that much more. You know,
the whole country is 20 trillion.
New York can't be worth much more than
one or 2 trillion of the 20 trillion. So,
you know, you're not that far off. So
the deal's not that spectacularly bad,
although it sounds ridiculous.
Anyway,
the point is you can do this in
your head and we can, uh, okay.
So now the next thing that you realize
in this example is how huge a difference
a percent makes. So why is
that so important? Well,
managers, hedge funds, we all
charge a percent interest.
So look at what's happening. I
mean, if you look at our Indian,
you know,
investment of 24 and you look,
I don't know how many years you want
to look over it, but you can look over,
you know, 36 years.
That's a sort of typical,
you're young making an investment
when you get old. What's the, um,
you know,
what's the,
what's the difference?
This was sick.
This was the 6% growth and this was
the 7% growth. This is the difference.
And this is the,
I guess the percentage difference.
So it's 28%.
Uh,
of course they didn't label these,
but uh,
okay.
Yeah. So this is the, this is the,
this is the difference and
this is the percent difference.
So the percent difference. Okay. So that
why just showed it to you over 36 years.
It's, um, 28.6% difference.
So a typical, you know,
you're putting money away right now,
you might be giving it to some fun.
You might be investing it in
your, you know, your, you know,
whatever fund you're investing in it,
they could be charging 1% interest and it
seems, what's 1%? It's a tiny amount. 1%,
you know, but over 30 years,
they're taking 28% of your money.
36 years with the Indians over 360 years.
We saw that it was an astronomical
amount that they took.
They took almost all your
money, right? So, I mean,
look at the percentage that got taken.
So 768 billion versus
um,
uh,
versus 24 billion. I mean,
what could be, I mean,
it's astounding.
Okay.
So giving 1% away to a money
manager is giving away a fortune.
If you think you're going to stick
with the money manager for a reasonable
amount of time. So if you want the
secret to how hedge funds make money,
that's the first way they make it. The
most important way. They charge a fee.
That sounds small,
but it adds up over a years and it
amounts to a huge amount of money.
Now you can make it much smart.
Why does it amount to so much money?
Because the money that you put in
the fund you're keeping in the fund.
So it's growing and growing and growing.
So they're taking 1% of your hundred
$24 today. That sounds like nothing.
But the money's still there
and now 40 years later,
they're taking 1% of a much bigger number.
That's why the number gets to be so large.
Okay,
so that's the second thing. All
right, so now let's keep going.
So that's the basic a thing.
So now let's go to define a few
terms that everybody should know.
What's a coupon bond?
A coupon bond is the
simplest kind of bond.
The first one that was created and it
pays a fixed coupon dollars every period
for t periods. The t's called the
maturity. So it's defined by the coupon,
which is the fixed payment it
makes every year until period t,
which is the maturity of the bond.
And then it also at the end of
period t pays a principal. Okay.
Which is um, so here, which is usually a,
how the bond is a denominated,
I'm the face value of the bond and
pays the principal or face value.
So typically that's usually
a hundred or a thousand.
So a coupon might be a six, six, six, six,
106. Okay. That would be a
6% coupon bond. You know,
you can also define the coupon
by the percentage of the,
of the face that it pays every year as
a coupon. So little c is the percentage.
So 0.06, uh, times a hundred is
six, six, six, six, six, six.
I can use B s, you
know, big C is $6. Okay.
So it's defined by its percentage,
by the face and by the maturity.
So the first obvious thing to say is if
the interest rate is 6% and the bond is
paying a 6% coupon than it
has to be worth its face.
So it's always assume the faces a
hundred so why is that? Because if a,
okay, so why is that? It doesn't seem
totally obvious because you know you're,
the formula is you take a hundred times.
See that's the first payment divided
by one plus AI than a hundred times c
divided by one plus r squared,
et cetera.
It's not so obvious that's going to turn
out to be equal to a hundred but so you
just have to think for a second why that
should be in the way to think of this
as if you had $100 in
the bank at 6% interest,
you could get $106 the next year,
take the six and throw it and spend it.
You'd still have $100 in the bank
that would give you $6 again,
the next year you could take that $6 in,
spend it,
you'd still have $100 in the bank.
And You keep doing that until the last
year when you've got $106 so at 6%
interest putting the money in the
bank and spending the coupons,
we'd give you exactly the same cash flow
as the bonds giving you. So therefore,
uh, whether you put the money at
the bank at 6% interest or keep or,
or by the bond,
you're getting the same cash flow.
So it has to be by no arbitrage that
the initial outlay was the same.
So it has to be $100.
Okay, well that obvious,
okay?
Now you can prove it many different ways.
Now you could also imagine keeping
a bond forever paying 6% interest.
Then you get, if $100 a 6%
interest would give you $6 forever.
So if there were 6% interest
and you're getting $12 forever,
how much would that be worth
at? 6% interest. $12 forever.
Okay,
6% interest and you get $12
every year forever. What's that?
Okay,
how many dollars is that worth originally?
If the interest rate that all banks are
giving and the whole world's agreeing 6%
is the rate of interest and someone's
offering to give you $12 every year
forever. How much money into present
value terms is it giving you?
Yeah,
200 right? Because 200 at 6%
would give you $12 every year.
Okay. So these are the most basic
formulas to keep in mind. Okay.
So those, you know, you may be hearing
these things for the first time.
So it, it's, it takes a
second to adjust to it,
but there's no cleverness involved
in figuring these out. Now what's,
so we've got,
we've got the doubling rule,
we've got a coupon bonds and now,
so that's simple. Now somewhat
subtler thing is an annuity. Okay?
So an annuity pays you a fixed
amount for a fixed number of years.
So it doesn't pay the principal
at the end. So pays that.
C is supposed to be a
capital city and pay C, c, c,
C for a fixed number of years.
So it's a t period annuity.
Now annuities also can be
changed in two important ways.
They can be indexed to inflation. That's
a much better annuity. Cause now you're,
you're, you're, you're, you're, you
know, you're protected against inflation.
It also could be time to
last the rest of your life.
So we're going to come to this
when we talk about social security,
the most important annuity by far and
the whole economy is the social security
annuity. Once you retire and
you're in social security,
they figure out what your coop,
what your coupon is going to be.
Every year it's you, I'll tell you
the formula and a couple of classes.
So depending on how
much you've contributed,
they calculate what your
coupon is every year.
And so from the day you turn 65 for the
rest of your life, you get the same,
see inflation corrected.
So we're going to have to talk about
why they decided on that contract.
But anyway, that's an annuity. So
that depends on the length of life.
Okay. So you know, these annuities
are famous in history, Jane Austen,
the sense and sensibility said
it was a disaster. You know,
because whenever you give someone
an annuity, they live forever.
And she said that,
you know,
some character says her mother gave
the servants in the houses, uh,
annuities after their, you know,
their husbands died. And, uh,
she figured that they were so
old. Now, she gave the annuities,
they were servants of her mother's and
she gave them the annuity after their
husbands died. And, uh, you
know, Allison say we're so old.
She figured if she paid him a few
years and that'd be the end of it.
And they just went on and on and on
and on, and it was just, you know,
she got tired of giving them
all the money. But anyway,
so obviously when you're
giving a life annuity,
you have to calculate how long
the person's going to live.
And so we're going to come back to
that. The selection of, you know,
who takes annuities? Do they know that
they're going to live longer or not?
Anyway, that markets all screwed up
and we're going to come to that later.
But it's a famous market,
the annuity market. Now,
how can you figure out the
value of an annuity? Okay,
so this is a very simple
thing to do. Uh, once you've,
once you've come this far,
so this is the next thing to remember.
So I remember an annuities paying c, c, C,
c up to period t
here,
the periods t.
Okay,
so how much should this be
worth the present value?
What is the present value
today at time zero? Well,
we know that if it actually went forever,
see,
see like that it would be forever.
It would go see over the interest rate.
I annuities are often inflation correct.
And so I wrote are for
the real rate of interest.
So you could call it c over r
for the wheel rate of whatever.
Let's say it's nominal.
It's keep it too. I,
even though I haven't used that
notation there, so see you ever I,
if you get see dollars forever,
it's called a perpetuity.
A perpetuity. We already
know how to value. Okay.
We said see over I right at
6% for getting $12 a year.
It's worth $200.
Now what if it gets cut off at t?
Sounds like there's going to be a
very complicated formula to calculate,
but actually it's a very simple
formula. Okay. Why is that?
Because the t period,
so there,
here's the perpetuity
and the t period annuity
equals the perpetuity
minus a per perpetuity starting at time.
T minus perpetuity,
uh, uh, contracted
at time. T. All right,
so why, why is that? Here we
have a perpetuity at time.
Zero. You say to someone,
I'll,
you know the state,
the government says we'll pay you and
your descendants see dollars forever.
Okay, now you can. So we know what
that's worth. See override. Now we say,
suppose the state tells
you we're going to pay.
You see until time t what's that
worth? Well, it's worth this,
the whole thing minus this part of it,
but looked at from this
point of view here,
the whole part of it is
just a perpetuity again.
So it's just the perpetuity
which is see over I
minus c overall high,
another perpetuity here.
But as of time t cause that's, you
know, that's like the zero time.
The money's coming the next period
forever. Just like at time zero,
the money came starting up here
at one forever. So at time tier,
starting one period later forever.
So therefore it's this divided
by one plus r to the T.
Okay?
So let's just see over I times one
minus one over one plus r to the t.
So this is the next thing you
have to memorize, unfortunately,
but there are only a few
things you have to memorize.
So this is a very famous formula
for the value of an annuity. Okay?
So how do you, uh, okay,
so let's just do an example.
Suppose somebody,
maybe I can just do the same examples.
Okay, so you got the proof of that, right?
This is no surprise.
Okay? Remember the whole perpetuity is
obviously it's 6% and let's just think of
something at 6%.
So let's do the 6% annuity at
6% it's worth a 6% perpetuity.
$6, sorry, sick. Um, what am I saying?
A at 6% interest,
6% interest,
eight $12 perpetuity
is worth $200.
That was what we said before.
Okay,
so what is a 36 year?
so at 6% interest,
$12 perpetuity is worth $200.
So at 6% interest,
what is a $12 30 year?
Your annuity worth?
It's worth what?
It's all you.
That's how much is that worth?
Okay.
So if it went on forever,
it would be worth $200
if we cut it off after
30 years,
30 years is a bad time to cut it
off. Let's cut it off after. Um,
let's cut it off after 24 years.
Okay.
So you have 6% interest,
you get $12 not for every year
in the future, but for 24 years.
How much is it worth?
What can't be worth $200 cause
it'd be worth $200 for one forever.
So it's worth less than $200 but
how much less? So my uncle died,
left my sister and annuity. She just
had no idea what the annuity was, uh,
was worth. So do you have
any idea what it's worth?
Yup. Okay. It is. And
how did you get that?
It's 6% doubling your money. Yup.
Yup.
So it's one minus a quarter.
So that's three quarters and three
quarters times the 200 we got before.
It's 150 exactly. Exactly right. What
he said. So does everybody get that?
So let's say we have a,
let's try another one. Okay.
So let's suppose
I tell you,
um,
so let's suppose I pay $8.
See how long is this going to be?
Okay.
Okay. Suppose let's do, let's make
the, okay, let me say that again,
just in case you didn't follow that.
Cause I'm going to give a slightly
harder one this time. So he's saying,
how do you figure out
the value of an annuity?
Something by next class you'll
be able to do in your head,
it's going to be take the cash
flow that you get every year.
If it went on forever, it'd be so
easy to figure out what the value was.
If it's $12 at 6% interest,
that's like having $200 in the bank
because then you'd get at 6% interest.
You going to get $12 every year forever.
Okay?
So we know of that $12 a year forever is
clearly $200 that's see over I 12 of a
0.06 it's $200 blog.
It's going to get cut off when you are
24 so we're going to lose all this future
stuff. But the future is not worth very
much. Why isn't it worth worth very much?
Cause you know by the time we get here,
we've already discounted by a lot.
So a dollar starting here is actually
only a quarter of a dollar starting back
here because in 24 years at 6% interest,
you've doubled twice.
So it's worth a quarter. So you just
take a quarter of the same annuity.
So it's one minus,
it's it's a one minus a
quarter of the same annuity.
So the one that ends in 24 years is
like three quarters of the value of a
perpetuity. Three quarters of 200
is 150 okay. That's how we did it.
So let's just try a slightly,
let's reverse the thing.
Suppose we know the
present value is a hundred.
Suppose we know the present value is a
hundred you're now the company and you're
trying to figure out how much to pay.
Okay. So what is the SI going to be?
Let's say it's 8% interest.
Okay.
And just to, I'll just do the
same example in notes. Okay.
And the 30 years a typical thing. So it's
not going to work out exactly evenly.
So 8% interest for 30 years.
Okay?
So we know it's worth a hundred
all right? So let's get rid
of all me enrolled in stuff.
You don't have to board cluttered.
We've got something that's worth a hundred
okay,
here's the formula down here.
So the thing is worth a hundred
you know the interest rate is 8%
now and it's a 30 year annuity.
So somebody tells you the interest rate's
8% these days you're going to get a 30
year annuity, you've got $100 to invest,
and you go to the annuities company,
the insurance company,
you tell them I want an annuity.
How much did they give you every year
while you just have to figure out what C
is.
So you put c over 0.08
okay. So what does that tell
you? What would that be?
If it was a, what would they be
paying you? If it was a perpetuity,
they'd be,
you'd be paying you who's a perpetuity,
what would they be paying you?
They'd be paying $8 a year. Right? So,
but they're only going to
pay you for 30 for 30 years.
So how much are they going to pay
you? One plus I to the T. Okay,
so this is 1.08 1.08 to the 30th and
what's 1.08 to the 30th well 1.08 to the
30th by our rule is what?
It's equal to 1.08 to the 27th hey and
in nine years at 8% interest all doubles
after 27 years it's going
to double three times.
One point also oh eight
to the third power.
So after 27 years is going
to double or three times.
So that's eight by two to the third power
is eight and then 8% over three years.
[inaudible] eight ghost one oh eight
goes to about one 16 goes to about one 24
but you know it's going to grow
a little faster because you know,
1.08 times 1.08 is a little bit more
than 1.16 so it's going to grow to like
1.25 instead of 1.24.
So that's 10.
Okay?
So this is just one over 10.
So the whole thing is nine
tenths. So basically, uh,
you get almost all the value after third,
after 30 years at 8% interest.
It's such a high interest rate that
after 30 years you're getting nine tenths
and the value of the annuity,
okay,
so you're going to have to get
paid 10 nines. The uh, you know,
$8,000 it would have been $8,000.
If we're perpetuity,
you have to pay the guy a little bit more.
You have to get a little bit more
because only getting it for 30 years.
But because the interest rate's so high,
the stuff after 30 years isn't very
important. It's only, uh, you know,
you have to be given an extra 10th.
So it's 10, nine signs, 8,000.
So it's 8,888 is what you are
annuity's is going to be every year.
Okay. So just to summarize
it, to say it all again,
we know how to compute
perpetuities with ease.
And so if you want $100 and a coupon
forever and the interest rate's 8%,
there's just 8,000 forever. If you only
get it for a shorter amount of time,
obviously you have to get more.
How much more?
What depends each year for only 30 years.
It depends on how much
you're giving up at the end.
And at 8% you're only giving
up a 10th of the whole value.
So you have to be compensated for that
each year by getting 10, you know,
mine's of what you would've gotten before.
So we're up to 8,888 okay.
All right. So that's okay.
So those are all right.
So those are the words
that everybody has to know.
So let's just do a couple
more simple computations here.
Uh, just to give you an idea of
how Fisher helped here. Okay.
So I'm going to do a few mortgage things.
I'm going to do a few.
I haven't defined mortgage yet
the way. Why did I do that? Um,
so a mortgage is just a 30 year annuity,
a mortgage.
So one more thing on the mortgage
is an annuity. A fixed mortgage.
Okay. A fixed mortgage.
A fixed rate mortgage.
Okay.
Mortgage, uh, is define
by a principal.
Okay. So we're going to, when
we talk about the crisis,
this word principal will come up all
the time. So that's the face value.
The principal,
I'm mortgage coupon rate,
coupon rate,
and a principal and mortgage coupon rate,
and a maturity.
So the most common,
this is a fixed rate mortgage.
So the most common kind
of maturity is 30 years,
30 years is the most common. And then
sometimes they're 15 year mortgages.
And then there's a whole host of other
mortgages we're going to come to later
where there's floating interest rates.
So the 30 year mortgage,
how much do you have to pay?
Well, there's one, you know,
if it were on an annual payment and
it were an 8% mortgage for 30 years on
$100,000 so if it was $100,000 principal,
an 8% coupon,
okay,
okay. Uh, for 30,
we just calculated that
you would have to pay,
the payment would be $8,888 a year
because $8,888 a year discounted at 8% is
going to give you 100,000. Okay.
So that's how the mortgage works.
Once they've told you that.
So whenever you hear about a mortgage,
you always hear the mortgage rate,
that's the coupon rate. Okay.
The maturity is usually 30 years,
you know,
then you'd have to be told
how much the mortgage was for.
Then you can figure out what does the
guy have to pay every year. And it's,
you know,
you just figure out the annuity payment
that at this interest rate makes his
payments have present value with this
interest rate equal to the principal.
So he just saw his 8,888 a year.
And there's one more little
twist with mortgages. Okay.
So that's not literally
true. What I said. Mortgages
have monthly payments,
monthly payments.
Okay. Monthly payments,
their monthly payments. Uh,
and so the monthly rate,
yeah,
at monthly rate equal the coupon
divided by 12 so if it's an 8% mortgage,
then it means that they're,
they're taking two thirds.
So in this case we'd have 8% over 12
which equals two thirds of a percent.
Okay.
So the mortgage would be in a 0.67%
okay.
Okay. And so then you do
the monthly calculations,
you have to figure out the c such that
summation over one plus two thirds
percent.
That's 1.067 in other words,
1.0672 the t t equals one to three 60 has
to equal 100,000 that's how much you'd
have to, yeah. Hey, every
month. And so it wouldn't,
it wouldn't be 8,880 a year.
It'd be slightly more than
8,888 divided by 12 every month.
Okay. But anyway, these are just, okay,
so this is the last of these
definitions for today's class.
So everybody who's on Wall Street knows
what a perpetuity is and they know how
to compute its value at
a given interest rate.
They know what an annuity is and how to
compute its present value of mortgage is
almost the same thing as an annuity,
okay?
The only twist is that the mortgage is
competed monthly instead of annually,
but when they using a
monthly interest rate,
but when they say the
instead of telling you
the monthly interest rate,
they tell you the monthly interest rate
times 12. Okay? It's just a convention.
All right? So those are all the
things you have to memorize.
Now what?
Let's try to use the way we can think,
okay.
And do some practical problems here.
So here's one of my,
one of the simplest and most important
ones is let's say you're a Yale professor.
I gave this example in the very first
day of class. You're a Yale professor.
When I first gave the example a
few years ago when I, when I, uh,
wrote the notes,
the average Yale professor over,
so this was quite a few years ago,
eight or nine years ago,
was making 115,000 a
year. It has, it happens.
The average Yale salary now is
150,000 a year. Okay. But anyway,
when I wrote it,
it was 115,000 a year.
So let's suppose that
you're starting today,
this year's professors are making 115,000
and let's say your salary will go up,
go up
at 3% inflation
every year.
Okay? So, uh,
and that's inflation.
That's equal to the general inflation.
So your salary is keeping
pace with general inflation
and no more. So professors,
you know,
we're not doing that well.
So the salary is going is 115,000
now it would be 150,000 but anyway,
it was 115,000 on average.
And let's say you're just going to
be kept up with inflation. You know,
they're going to be, you're going to
be told every year you have a 3% raise.
But that's just going to
keep you up with inflation.
Now you know you're going
to work for 30 years,
let's say 30 years and
retire for 30 years.
A little ambitious about of
how long you're gonna live,
but let's just suppose that's what you
think you're going to live for 30 years
after that. So how much should you spend
every year? Well, you can't answer that.
And let's say you want level
level real consumption.
Yeah.
So you want to consume the same amount
every year for the rest of your life,
which is going to be 60
years, 38 Yale, 30 retired.
So how much do you spend every
year in, in consumption? Okay,
well you can't answer that until
you know the interest rate.
So let's say the interest rate,
the nominal interest rate
equals let's say a 5.3% about a
little bit more than 5.3% okay?
So phenomenal interest rate
is 5.3% inflation knows is
going to be 3% and you've
got 115,000 coming going up
with inflation every year.
How are you ever going to figure out how
much to spend starting next year when
your job starts? It looks like a
hopeless thing. You'd have to say, well,
if I get 115,000 next year, I consume
some of it. I put the rest in the bank.
It makes you no interest.
It grows at 5.3% but then inflation is
3% so I take that into account and figure
out how much to spend the year after that.
But then I'm gonna get 115,000 more.
That's all. Save something
maybe more for my next thing.
And then I'll deposit that in another
5.3% and I have to take into account
inflation at 3% wait, it sounds
like as you get very complicated,
how are you going to figure this out?
But in fact it's very simple and Irving
Fisher pointed the way to do it and we
can now do it in our heads.
Okay, so Fisher said,
don't figure out all this year
by year stuff it's going to be,
and don't get mixed up with the
rate of inflation. You don't,
you don't care about inflation,
you're going to look through the
inflation and only care about the real
consumption. So the fact is you care
about the real rate of interest.
So the real rate of interest,
one plus r equals one plus I
over the rate of inflation,
which equals 1.053 over one point,
uh,
old three,
which is about 1.0 to three right?
This is a,
we're doing things in our head now so we
have to be a little bit approximating.
So right,
if I divide this by this,
these numbers are so close to one that
I'm basically just subtracting the bottom
from the denominator,
from the numerator.
If I multiply one plus
g times one plus PSI,
all right,
one plus g times one plus R,
that's going to equal one
plus g Plus r plus Rg.
And if our is very cool, you know it
was point all three ours, you know,
if this is 0.02 and this is 0.03 then
the multiplication is 0.06 so this is
practically irrelevant. So multiplying
numbers like this or dividing them,
it's just like adding these things.
So it's just like adding,
taking this term and subtracting that.
Okay.
So when you get a number near one
divided by another number near one,
you just take the difference from one in
the numerator minus the difference from
one of the nominators is pretty close
to doing actually the division. Okay.
So this is about 2.3% interest.
So the real interest rate is
about 2.3% so Fisher would say,
Aha,
use the real rate of interest.
You're getting 115,000 wheel payments
every year for 30 years at a real interest
rate of 2.3% but we know what that is.
So what is 115,000 of real dollars every
year at a real rate of 0.0 to 3% we'll
remember what our formula was.
It's the cash you're getting every year,
two or perpetuity.
You got it every year forever.
It would just be the cash you're
getting divided by the interest.
So 115,000 that's over a 10th
of a million every year forever.
At 2.3% interest. That would be
worth, that's 5 million so far.
But you're not getting it every year.
You're getting it for 30 years.
So one minus 1.0 to
three to the 30th okay.
So what's that equal to?
No longer 5 million because that would be
getting the money forever.
Okay.
One Point Oh to three to the 30th is what?
Okay,
so we said that 2.3% interest,
it's 2.3 and the 72 is a,
you know,
2.3 times 30 or 69 so because it's close
to zero of the 69 rule almost works.
So anyway,
I'm proximation would say 2.3 and to 72
it was just a little bit over 30 okay.
So it doubles every 30 years
and you've got it for 30 years.
So it's just going to be to,
this number is about two right?
2.3% into 72 is approximately 30 so
every 30 years at this interest rate in
doubles.
So therefore you've got one
15,000 over 0.023 times.
One minus a half.
You've lost half the value
by not getting it forever.
So that's 2.5 million.
So Fisher says, look,
remember the budget set in and gee,
we studied budget set.
We put p one x one plus
p two x two plus P,
you know,
60 x 60 that's in the left hand side is
less than or equal to p one endowment,
one plus p two endowment to plus
p 30 times in diamond 30 okay,
you're getting hundred 15,000 of
wheel goods every year for 30 years.
P one is one over 1.0 to three p
two is one over 1.0323 squared,
et cetera.
So this revenue on the right is just the
annuity of 30 years of 115,000 of real
goods.
So it's worth 5 million
reduced because it's not a perpetuity.
It's only an annuity for 30 years.
And so it's worth 2.5 million.
So we've got the right hand side,
that's this 2.5 million.
Hey,
that's how much the present value.
So that's what I'm a professor at
Yale can look forward to his entire,
her entire career.
She started 10 or 20 years ago would
be all that you'll make two and a half
million in present value terms. She'd gone
to Wall Street, you know, in five years.
If she were Yale undergraduate,
Wendell,
what we'll Wall Street
in five or 10 years,
she'd be making more than that
every year. So what? Uh, so,
well not everybody, but
anyway, so um, okay,
so how much did she spend every
single year of her 60 year life?
Well,
so we have to figure out this
number, see the coupon, right?
We have to figure out how much can
we spend every year of her life.
What? See can she spend at
2.3% interest? We're now,
I have a 60 here. Okay. So,
so it's an annuity of 60 years of constant
consumption at this interest rate.
So how much is it worth?
Okay,
well I have to just figure
out 1.0 to three to the 60th.
One Point Oh to three to the 30th
was a half 1.0 to three to this I,
it was to 1.0 to three to the 60th
is four. So this is one fourth.
Hey, so, so we have three quarters
here. So this is, you know,
see over 0.023 times,
three quarters.
That's what we have. So you
multiply four thirds by 2.5 million,
you get 10 million equals 10
million over three equals point.
So it's a point,
this is a 0.023 times three
divided by three times 10 million.
We'll see. Okay. And so that's like 76,000
something.
Okay. Three and 2.0 to three is 76 and
then you have to figure out, you know,
what decimal place you're at and
you know it's going to be more,
it's going to be less than 115,000 so
it's gotta be some number that's close,
you know,
some reasonable percentage of 115,000
so it works out to 76,000 so that's it.
You could do that in your head.
I mean, not today, but you know,
after looking at it for,
you know,
by next time they'll be able
to do that in your head.
So this professor can figure out what
you should do. Seems like a hard problem.
You know,
it's life.
You've got to figure out what to do
every year and now you know how to do it
very easily.
Okay.
So any questions about this?
I want to do one more little example.
All right,
so let's do our heart or example.
When I was a,
it's easier computationally,
but harder conceptually when
I was just got tenure at eal,
uh, actually I had tenure for a few years.
You'll see why this is relevant. Um,
the president Benno Schmidt of Yale
said a horrible thing has happened.
Generations of yield presidents before me
have not realized that the buildings
were not getting the proper care.
There is deferred maintenance
generation after generation did know,
fixing up of the buildings.
I'm the first president who's going to
act responsibly and fix up the buildings.
And he said,
um,
I'm going to fix up the buildings.
And I can tell you that I've hired these
planners and they've come and done an
exhaustive study and we have
to spend 100 million a year
for 10 years each year.
I said each year,
each year for 10 years to fix
up the buildings properly.
That plan,
by the way,
is the thing that got turned
into fixing one college a year.
So a hundred million for 10 years.
That's what we need.
These presidents before
me have overlooked it.
They spent as if we don't have to keep up
the buildings. I recognize the problem,
I'm going to correct it. This is a huge
expense. They didn't take into account.
We have to reduce the budget.
So how much do you reduce the budget by
how much he cuts would he have made in
his first, in that first year, how would
you figure it out, what to do? Okay,
so what he did is he recommended
firing 15% of the faculty,
which didn't go over very well. And
the faculty, it was an amazing thing.
How can you, you know,
there's no structure at Yale.
The president runs heal.
There's no senate, there's no
labor union, there's no nothing.
It's just the president.
Suppose the president announces,
I'm going to get rid of
15% of the faculty. What is
the faculty supposed to do?
So,
I mean there's no mechanism.
So what happened is the old deans who
are no longer deans, they were just old.
Almost all of them were men.
Again, I guess old guys,
they got together and said,
well, we have no power. We have no
position. But we used to be deans at Yale.
It's up to us to do something.
We're going to appoint a committee
who's going to examine the logic of the
president's decision.
So we're going to a 0.6 people that
we're going to pick out of the blue and
they're going to make a report to the
faculty and tell us what to do. So, um,
I was one of the six and the
other five guys were pretty, uh,
nervous. Well, we are all
were nervous about, um,
actually getting up in front of the
president and the provost and the Dean and
saying that it was all wrong
and he shouldn't do this. So,
but we had tenure so we couldn't get up
and say whatever the hell we wanted to.
Okay. So what did I say? What would you
have said if you were me? Okay. Now,
the whole budget was,
the whole budget of Yale was 1 billion
equals annual budget
and a lot of things you can't cut.
So not as a hundred million a
year is 10% of the annual budget.
Okay. So he basically said,
well, we've got a, you know,
we've got 100 million a year, we're at
a cutout, you know, 10% of the budget.
And since there's some things
we can't get rid of, you know,
we got to keep making fixed payments
and the faculty something, you know,
of course I'm not going to
fire the tenured faculty.
I'm going to fire, you know,
people who aren't tenured
and when faculty retire,
I just won't hire anyone to replace them.
That's how I'm going to get rid of the
fact that that's how he got the 15%.
So what would you, uh,
what would you have done?
What would you have said if you were me,
don't do it,
but what else would you have said?
What calculation can you do?
So you know now what to say.
You can't think of what to say.
So what would you say? Sorry,
I'll come to you in a second.
What's a reasonable number? How would
you think of a reasonable number?
Let's take his facts correct. In fact,
they didn't turn out to be that far off.
I mean, the central, the, the, the,
the people he hired were pretty good.
Okay.
At assessing how much stuff
needed to be done. Yes.
I guess the first thing you do,
10 years
and then what?
Okay.
It sounds like couldn't start now.
He says the first thing he'd do is he
think about what a 10 year annuity at $100
million a year is worth. Okay. So why
would he want to do that? So that's good.
That's what he should do. That's how I
started. But what's the relevance of that?
Yup.
Right.
So he could,
yeah.
Okay. So he could say, alumni,
please do something about, you know,
it's $1 billion, not quite something
less than a billion dollars.
We'll figure it out in a minute. So
alumni please hand over, you know,
three quarters of $1 billion and a,
I want to have to fire my faculty.
Okay. He could try that. What if the
alumni didn't come through? Now you,
I know you're going to say something.
I'm going to give him a couple of
more people a chance back there. Yep.
Okay.
So you would short 10 year annuity.
What were you gonna say?
Yup.
Okay, now we're on the
right track. Exactly. So I'm
going to go a step further.
I went a step further. I said,
you know, Yale is forever.
So what he's telling us,
what he's telling us is that we need to
catch up to where we should be to make
up for all that lost, you know,
maintenance. He's not saying, by the way,
that the presidents who built,
you know,
the colleges and the 1920s and stuff
weren't paying attention to the physical
plant. He was talking about
the few generations before him.
So once we make up for those losses
and then return to a steady state,
you know, after spending the a
hundred million a year for 10 years,
we'll be back to Yale in a steady state.
Yale is going to go on forever.
So the point is,
why should the 10 years,
why should the next 10 years generation
pay for something that's going to,
you know, make Yale better for
the whole infinite future of Yale.
So I said, how much would every
generation, not just today,
but forever in the future,
have to consume less in order to
make up for this one shot problem,
this deferred maintenance that a couple
of generations of Yale presidents, uh,
didn't put in. So in other words, um,
I would figure out the present
value of the 10 year a hundred mil
annuity.
Okay.
And then I would set that equal
to what coupon a perpetuity
gives you the same present
value. Okay? So, all right,
so how can you figure that out?
So in other words,
if you lose 100 million for 10 years,
that's equivalent to how
much less for every year.
Okay. So, uh, it turns out
to be quite a big deal.
So it depends on what
the interest rate is.
So let's say now it happens
that Yale has an interest rate.
Yale always uses this 5% rule.
So if you take are equal to 5%,
um,
that's supposedly the money.
Yale,
after inflation is confident that it can
get on incent Dalman usually it thinks
it can get more.
You'd figure out what the,
what the annuity value is of 100 million.
Okay. So I'm over time. So anyway,
we're going to have to, so the punch
line is it comes to 32 million a year,
not 100 million a year.
We'll do this calculation next time,
and you don't need to fire 15% of
the faculty to get 32 million a year.
So we'll start next time.